Hochzeit Mitternacht ist die Maske
Geschichte in Deutschland jedenfalls in
Bussen und Bahnen viele Bürger atmen
erleichtert auf wer will kann sie
natürlich auch weitertragen was
Gesundheitsminister Lauterbach ja auch
empfiehlt schon lange aber es umstritten
wie sinnvoll die Maske je war eine
aktuelle Studie hat jetzt gezeigt der
Nutzen war wohl eher gering vor allem
weil die Maske aber auch eines Symbol
Vorsicht wir haben eine schwere Pandemie
er Herr Friedrich das Ende der
maskenpflicht ist das längst überfällig
oder halten Sie das womöglich für
gefährlich nein um Gottes Willen es ist
mehr als überfällig keine konnte ja
jemandem erklären warum man jetzt
zwischen Schweiz und Deutschland zum
Beispiel im Zug noch Maske tragen musste
dann wieder nicht wenn man in
Niederlande gefahren ist und es war mehr
als überfällig also was ist der
Unterschied zwischen dem dem dem dem
zweiten februar und dem 7 April liegt
dann das Coronavirus irgendwie die Füße
auf dem Tisch und sagt so das war's also
es ist eigentlich nur noch macht
Geplänkel und transalieren der Bürger
der Freiheitsrechte es macht überhaupt
gar keinen Sinn mehr vor allem die
Zahlen sprechen ja ganz deutlich dass
die Inzidenzen zurückgehen ich denke mal
die Politik wollte noch mit einigermaßen
erhobenen Haupt irgendwie aus dem ganzen
Schlamassel rauskommen wir sehen ja auch
die Ratten verlassen des Sinken des
Schiff Drosten oder auch Herr Wähler und
dahingehend mehr als überfällig und ich
habe heute im Zug habe ich es auch
gehört die Leute haben dann uploaddiert
als der Schaffner gesagt hat so ab heute
keine maskenpflicht mehr sie können Sie
gerne abnehmen die Leute waren einfach
freudig und ich habe weniger als 10% der
Menschen gesehen mit Maske und glauben
Sie denn trotzdem wird ja auch weiterhin
gewarnt weiterhin die Maske empfohlen
haben Sie das Gefühl dass man fast
versucht die Pandemie noch so ein
bisschen künstlich zu verlängern oder
warum gibt es diese Warnungen und
Warnungen noch ja man möchte wohl
versuchen mit mit erhoben noch
rauszukommen aus der ganzen Geschichte
aber Fakt ist ja auch es ist völlig
Evidenz befreit ne also wir wurden
einfach ja auf gut deutsch
verarscht muss man schon fast sagen
letzten Jahre und jetzt kommt ja für die
Wahrheit ans Licht und man möchte
natürlich nicht dass die Menschen dann
irgendwann auf die Straße gehen oder
rebellieren aber es müssen Konsequenzen
folgen also einer Lauterbach sollte
schon längst mal den Hut nehmen oder die
Maske lieber lieber gleich gehen und
natürlich auch die Herr Drosten Herr
wiele und so weiter und die Bürger
fühlen sich auf ja veräppelt muss man
ganz klar sagen dass wir hier als einer
der letzten Bastionen eigentlich
geistiger Amokfahrer waren und versucht
haben das am Leben zu erhalten und ich
glaube bei Lauterbach geht es auch um
die politische Karriere tatsächlich sie
was sind trägst du weiter noch Maske
freiwillig in gewissen Situationen also
wirklich
[Gelächter]
sogar passiert da hatte ich aus Versehen
zwei Masken auf da hatte ich irgendwie
eine Aufgabe aus dem Bus nachdem wie
eine zweite Maske plötzlich ähm genau
die Maske vom Gesicht gerissen in
anderer Hinsicht immer das Bild erlaubt
ist wenn ich höre das schaffe das z.B
Kinder eine 12-jährige irgendwie aus dem
aus dem Regionalexpress werfen irgendwo
eine Milchkanne quasi weil die irgendwie
nicht die richtige Maske dabei hatte
oder so da werden Menschen gefährdet
worden da sieht man ähm wie Menschen
sich dazu sehr billigen Vollstreckern
machen von Regeln die mindestens mal
sehr fragwürdig sind das fand ich
erschreckend aber auch eine interessante
Erkenntnis über unsere Mitmenschen wie
man hier so ticken Herz wie geht es
ihnen da erzählen sie sich eher zum Team
Vorsicht ab und zu noch die Maske an
also ich lebe ja in Wien und das ist
glaube ich mittlerweile die einzige
Stadt wo man im öffentlichen Nahverkehr
noch Masken tragen muss und das ist
mittlerweile auch schon eine muss man
sagen ein bisschen perverse Situationen
wenn man über die Landesgrenze quasi
fährt muss man sie dann anziehen oder
eben auch abziehen
also ganz klar jetzt auch mal in
Richtung Zukunft blicken muss man sagen
es ist jetzt indemisch es ist jetzt
vorbei jetzt ist die Phase der
Aufarbeitung und natürlich also man
kennt es aus dem asiatischen Raum da
tragen schon ein paar Menschen manchmal
Masken ja zum Thema krankeneinrichtung
und so weiter wenn es notwendig ist dann
sei es so ich glaube es geht eher um die
symbolträchtigkeit und gar nicht mehr so
sehr wirklich um das virologische in der
ganzen Frage und diese symboltätigkeit
im Bus und Bahn ist jetzt auf jeden Fall
schon einmal weg welche anderen
Maßnahmen können aus ihrer Sicht herr
Hofmann denn noch sofort beendet es gibt
ja noch einige beispielsweise
Impfpflicht für die Bundeswehr zum
Beispiel aber auch weiterhin
massenpflicht natürlich wenn man
Krankenhäuser betritt gibt es aus ihrer
Sicht etwas von dem man sich
verabschieden sollte also das was ich ja
jetzt abzeichnet ist das für die
allermeisten Maßnahmen sowieso nie
irgendeine Form von wissenschaftlicher
vidence bestanden hat man versucht sich
ja jetzt raus zu reden in dem Sinne von
ja mit das würden wir heute nicht mehr
so machen das ist aber nicht die Frage
die Frage ist ob man es damals hätte
schon wissen können wissen zu müssen
oder es möglicherweise auch gewusst hat
was man da eigentlich macht
Impfpflicht ist noch mal noch mal ein
Thema für sich wenn ich mir allerdings
anschaue vorsichtig formuliert dass wir
in Deutschland eine bisher nicht
erklärte Übersterblichkeit im Bereich
von 20 Prozent haben die wir in
zweieinhalb Jahren Pandemie nicht hatten
und keiner anfängt Fragen zu stellen wo
die herkommt sondern alle möglichen
Reserve Erklärungen aus dem Hut
gezaubert werden was habe ich neulich
gelesen in Japan sagt das
Gesundheitsministerium die Leute sterben
an herz-id und nierenkow